be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
okay so we are getting into Justice
League the Justice Doom Ward and
initially I thought doing this video
like doing that this story arc is a
singular story unto itself but for a lot
of people who are reading either you're
the villain or just the the Justice
League events itself or at least getting
caught up it can all be really confusing
right in terms of like Perpetua and the
multiverse and all these forces and
everything that are going on and so the
cool thing about this is that while
other writers like Joshua Williamson is
writing the flash and he's using like
you know there's kind of the the
induction of these other forces you know
the still force and sage force and so on
and so forth we're gonna kind of ignore
that not insofar as it's not in an
continuity or not in existence I mean it
is but we're gonna kind of ignore what's
going on there and we're gonna focus
strictly on what's happening here
because what scott snyder really does is
essentially explain it all and the
reality of this is it's kind of the
question why did DC wait so long and
this really kind of reveals it in terms
of the events going on here but the cool
thing about it is that this really picks
up with the idea between the the Justice
League and the the legion of Doom's
going to war against each other and a
reality that's how it is that the events
of year the villain are set up right
like you're the villain is interesting
insofar as as like you know the offer of
Lex Luthor right basically like he
travels around from place to place to
various villains essentially and offers
them you know it makes the offer like do
they want to join his Legion of Doom The
Joker turned it down and a lot of a lot
of a no turn it down but a lot of them
have also accepted it too and so as a
result of that it's basically you know
the the the offer set of events or the
offer storyline in DC is really more
just like back up features like one page
you know where two page parts at the end
of a story where Lex Luthor is basically
building up his own Legion of Doom
that's really all it is and in reality I
wouldn't have called it like you're the
villain I would just call it like the
rise of the Legion of Doom or something
like that you know and it just would
have tied into and made a lot more sense
in terms of like if only you know only
because of its namesake but at the very
least here with Lex Luthor forming his
own Legion of Doom for the purpose of
basically serving Perpetua and then the
Justice League standing against him
that's kind of where things are at the
moment so what this does is it actually
picks up seemingly like with the battle
with the war seemingly over right like
the the Legion of Doom having basically
won and what's cool about this is we get
this depiction of Lex Luthor who
basically uses all these forces at his
disposal right like the Silph force the
ultraviolet lantern for Selassie one
familiar remember the ultraviolet
lanterns are basically lanterns who can
bring out essentially the worst in
people right like all the raw negative
emotions are all kind of brought to the
surface unlike most of the
other Lantern cores that really get
their power from a central power battery
the ultraviolet Lantern core is
basically fed by Umbridge this beam that
existed outside the source wall and then
once the source wall was broken made its
way into the main DC Universe again
we've got a video on like what the
ultraviolet lanterns are so you'll find
that down in the description if you want
a more nuanced and a more detailed
explanation there but the long and short
of it is that everything that's going on
right now that is to say Lex Luthor
basically killing all the members of the
Justice League basically destroying any
opposition that he has is really more of
a vision of sorts that's given to them
by will painting by storm man right and
this is important because what it does
is it basically shows the Justice League
this is what you guys are gonna be
dealing with this is what you guys are
gonna be coping with at the moment this
is how bad things are popping off and so
what the way this plays out it's really
interesting the way this plays out is
will Payton basically says like like in
order to essentially pull this off if we
faced off against Lex Luthor as he
stands now we'll lose just because of
the fact that his his the the fraction
of the totality the device that
basically allowed him to essentially
bring back Perpetua and in turn allows
two seemingly channel some of his energy
or at least most of his energy is much
bigger than will Payton's basically so
essentially like he can tap into more
that power than will paint in camp and
so the argument is we need to go to like
two different points in time outside of
the present day in order to access these
various you know remainders of the of
the totality remember this is an
artifact that when it came flying
through in and landed on earth in the
main DC Universe it also breached the
barriers of space and time just because
of the fact that space and time are
synonymous you can't have one without
the other and so it basically left
fractions of itself throughout the time
stream and the two big fractions they
need would equal a power or seemed to
rival the power of Lex Luthor and give
them a fighting chance and so because of
that what the Justice League ends up
doing is basically bringing together the
entirety of its team right like the
whole totality of its team you got
Shazam here you've got like like Black
Canary
you've got Supergirl you've got all
these various characters here um all of
whom are are essentially like fighting
on behalf of the Justice League and
trying to see this mission come to its
fruition now this is where the
explanation begins to come into play and
this is why it matters so much is
because what we end up finding out here
from will paint in the way this plays
out is that at some point or another
Perpetua was basically created by what
was called this source right and the
source it's one of these things that
DC's never fully bothered to like go on
and explain in its entirety if you go
back can you read the old Jack Kirby
comics right the old fourth-world comics
and things like that
the source
basically God but then you go into like
the Vertigo line and then like God is
there like like it's called the presence
right so like God actually exists but
for the most part dc's kind of treated
it insofar as the source is essentially
God to a degree and then like God has
different aspects right so like God's
judgment comes in the form of the
Specter different things like that
DC really treats their kind of source of
creation as a little more ambiguous
regardless of the circumstance the idea
behind this was that the source
essentially created Perpetua alongside
of a host of other individuals that
would go forward and essentially create
like universes and multiverses right
they would create life so very celestial
esque from Marvel Comics in terms of
their form and function the difference
is that unlike unlike the the
individuals that she fought beside or at
least kind of existed beside perpetual
wanted to bring down the various you
know I guess parents for lack of a
better word and this essentially led to
her creating like what what would
eventually become humans and Martians
right in the sense that as lex luthor
exists exist now he's what perpetual
originally created and then in turn they
basically split off as time went on then
you got humans and he got martians as a
result of that lex luthor is kind of the
first step in a return to the the
various kind of source of beings that
perpetuo created ultimately this led to
a kind of civil war sorts where you had
perpetual facing off against the monitor
the anti-monitor
and the forger of worlds and they in
turn imprisoned her behind the source
wall
because that with the new multiverse
basically being created as it exists now
kind of wiping away what she did and
then the the monitor anti-monitor in the
the forger of worlds creating like a new
multiverse this basically leads to
things as they exist at the moments
that's why you have the Speed Force
you've got the emotional spectrum as it
exists the various Lantern cores it
exists out there everything outside of
the ultraviolet Lantern's basically
you've got the sphere of gods and
presumably the rock of eternity and all
that kind of good stuff what what will
Peyton basically says is on the other
side of that coin are basically all the
the seven hidden energies of creation as
they were used by perpetuate basically
what she created when she created her to
her dark multiverse basically like her
evil version of the multiverse more or
less and that's when you start getting
into into all the various forces that
are kind of coming into fruition around
the still force a sage force all that
kind of good stuff those are all the
things that Lex Luthor can essentially
tap into if he's able to harness like
the full totality of what he can do and
that's why when you looked at the
beginning of the story the Justice
League was utterly destroyed because
they never really had a chance to face
off against such a sheer level of power
and so with that being the case what
you've basically got here is
you have shard of the totality in the
past which the Justice League has to get
and then a shard of the totality in the
future with the Justice League has to
get and then bring them all together in
the present day and then presumably
they'll stand a fighting chance and so
it's a cool little moment here like when
you get this this explanation in terms
of how it all works which in reality
having like that condensed in a concise
explanation is kind of long overdue
right like having a whole one-shot comic
that explains you but doesn't in a murky
way is okay but at the end of the day
like you know especially me I do much
better when I have like a clear and
concise short explanation on something
so it'll have to like hunt all over the
place or trying to decipher clues or
different things like that it's
interesting it kind of depends on the
story but the long and short of this is
that with Lex Luthor's Legion of Doom
fully assembled the other half of this
is they also know what the Justice
League is doing and the reason why is it
really comes out of the issue before
this which isn't super important I mean
it is important in so far as like what
you learned from it but basically djaro
had kind of taken over the the Justice
League to a degree nothing anything
insane it was like nefarious or anything
like that but djaro is a small piece of
Starro and Starro had been destroyed at
one point but is basically regrowing
under the control of Lex Luthor and so
because star au is regrowing he's able
to reach out into his smaller little
tidbits there here and there which comes
in the form of djaro and because djaro
had taken over the minds of the Justice
League it means that djaro read their
minds and in turn star ov now knows
everything that Justice League is going
to do so essentially this battle is done
before it's won and it's kind of a it's
a cool little moment there because what
it does is it creates a branch right it
creates the ability for the the Legion
of Doom to essentially use star au as a
means to spy on his djaro counterpart
and then watch the Justice League all
the time so this whole discussion that
they've had this whole plan that they've
put together you know with the help of
will Payton is all now known by the
Legion of Doom and so it's basically
like okay so like there's seemingly
screwed they're basically screwed like
there's really not much they can do at
the same time they've also got a
saboteur in their ranks that when the
portals are created that allow them to
enter into the timestream it's basically
sabotage they don't end up exactly where
they're supposed to or at least it
doesn't seem to be the case right you
end up picking up with Jon Stewart and
you pick up with the flash both of whom
are you know arrived in the past but
they don't arrive in the past as its
supposed to exist right now they arrive
in the past as if has already been
conquered by Perpetua and Oliver various
forces right so it's one of these weird
little scenarios because Hypertime in DC
is is really like an over complicated
mess it was the attempt of DC to
basically keep what they did after
crisis on Infinite Earths right before
Christ on Infinite Earths you had a
multiverse you had multiple realities
each one having its own version to
Justice League or any number of
combinations right having no Justice
League at all having just like a series
of heroes here and there and different
things like that when crisis on Infinite
Earths happened DC eliminated all of
that I they said okay there's only one
universe the issue is that it limited
the heck out of their ability to write
stories right like how do you write
stories that are interesting where they
go to a far-flung future they go to some
scenario where things played out
differently and and so on and so forth
and so wounded up happening is with Mark
Waid and a couple others DC invented
hyper time and hyper time if you can
imagine it in your head is one of these
points where if you start from point A
and you go to point B if you look at it
as a single timeline it's just point A
to point B it's a straight line that's
basically it with hyper time what you
get is point a and then you curve up and
come down to point B and that curve is
like some alternate reality where the
flash killed everybody and then you've
got one workers down from point A to
point B and that curve is an alternate
reality where Superman killed everybody
it's a way for DC to basically say
there's alternate timelines and they all
branch off from a singular point in time
but they all coalesce and basically
arrive in a guaranteed future they're
there but it's like they're not there
right I mean it's like one of those
things that work no matter what you do
you can't change it essentially there's
no way to undo that timeline it's I
think it's kind of murky and I think
it's a mess
and I think it's unnecessary and I think
it's over complicated in reality I
either pick alternate realities and just
go with the Marvel formula or don't
right it's just Marvel's formula for
alternate realities is infinitely easy
to understand right like branch universe
theory if it exists there exists an
alternate reality for it and then
alternate reality exists because
something in the main Marvel Universe
happened that caused it but regardless
of the situation you also end up picking
up with Superman Wonder Woman and Batman
who of course are sent into this future
and in turn like when they arrived there
this hotel he's conquered everything and
of course they're rescued by kid command
II now the character of command II uh I
guess command II I mean command II I'm
not really you know III call it command
II maybe it's came and II I'm not a
hundred percent sure how you pronounce
it but he basically comes from an
old-school comic that was actually self
titled command II command of the ongoing
series which was lost in 1972 um
technically it was called command II the
last boy on earth and the way this
played out was that in this alternate
reality which I think was designated
earth 86 I'm not gonna swear to that I
want to say there's two different
iterations there's earth 86 and earth
295 but basically the long and short of
it was that after this natural
stur especially when it came to like
radiation the fallout of nuclear war
this essentially permeated a handful of
animals both being experimented on by a
particular doctor as well as whatever
animals were left around the environment
and over the course of time they became
anthropomorphic so think Planet of the
Apes except more than just Apes and in
turn these this basically led to Kamandi
being the last boy who was left on earth
the last human being of sorts what Scott
Schneider really seems to be doing here
which I'm not have idli against it is
taking the concept of Kamandi and then
just rolling it in right now and just
kind of saying okay here's a more
updated depiction of the character he
hails from a universe where the great
cataclysm the great you know disaster
that was prophesized by the people who
inhabited earth at the time before it
all took place was actually the arrival
of Perpetua and essentially the
recreation of the multiverse why we can
just kind of go with that and take it as
an explanation
it works command ease obscure enough
where where Scott Steiner can really
kind of do what he wants with him and
then just sort of call it a day most
people probably never heard of them or I
never heard of the character or anything
along those lines but the fact remains
that when it comes to this the arrival
of the league here and basically being
saved by these animal men essentially
indicates that there is some measure of
resistance against the forces of
Perpetua and lex luthor and so on and so
forth which kind of makes sense right I
mean it'd be somewhat bleak and really
hopeless if it turned out to be like a
forever I'm sorry a future what was what
was that um um I keep on to say future
imperfect but that's not right it's not
it's not called future imperfect what is
it called
oh my god Gordon do not delete this
segment like people have to understand
how my brain works and me trying to
figure these things out because I feel
like there's fans right now who are
screaming the name into their monitors
and or skewing the name into their
phones or whatever and I'm just sitting
here like struggling um it's not
future's end I think it is futures and I
think that's what it's called I can't
remember ah I got a little bit into it
and I was like this is garbage
and then closed it which I imagine most
people won't disagree with littles gotta
be like you were kind of right to make
that call that story's pretty bad uh but
it'd be different if it was something
bleak like that right we're like
everybody's screwed basically
ah but to have a kind of resistance
force basically means that like there's
still remnants out there there's still
factions out there and if it's Kamandi
and the animal man well then there could
be various other individuals out there
now it could also just be like Scott
Snyder using this as a way to just kind
of springboard a new command e-series
you know just kinda like we're gonna
talk about command e now and and whether
or not that that's popular kind of
remains to be seen but here's the big
takeaway from this all right here's the
big
the big thing for all this and when I
saw this it like I almost popped it was
insane like I got I got to this and I
was just like I was like holy cow right
so like you pick up with with Jon
Stewart and with the flash and with this
this future they're looking at you know
and this this landscape so obviously
we're talking about two different
futures but with this future that
they're looking at in this landscape
like everything seems to be just like
totally you know kind of collapse and
what's left of civilization is living in
like huts and these little makeshift
buildings and different things like that
and suddenly they're met by the arrival
like they they have like this giant
green ring that circles around them and
it's just like okay so like what are the
world is going on and my first thought
when I saw this is all like okay cool
like other guys who are gonna be against
who are gonna be against like Perpetua
and lex and all them and whatever this
multiverse is or there's kind of
existing in this universe whatever this
universe happens to be I'm kind of
curious who these guys are gonna be I
turn the page instead it was the Justice
Society of America and I was like what
in the hell like I was a dude man let me
tell you something yeah always do my
mind was blown always like dude this is
bonkers man who the JSA and here's the
thing it's the whole JSA right like
Sandman Johnny Thunder like Jay Garrick
uh Alan Scott dr. fate I was dude Hawk
man I was like dude what are the world's
going on that guy who's like the Panther
lookin guy that I never cared enough to
learn about like it's it's crazy to see
that I was like dude this is this is
nuts man so like the JSA is not really
back in so far as they're back in the
main DC Universe I think that's confined
to Geoff Johns but we get to see the JSA
man who cares how they appear man these
dudes could all be wearing underpants
and I'd be like JSA son let's get to it
did I be hyped and I am well that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here two
comments explained make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the Rob for if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you guys drop a like and I
will catch you all later purse
[Music]